hello everyone I'm Jen product manager
on Rainbow six siege and we are so happy
to be here today to talk about at last
operations coloring our latest title
update in the game I know that the chat
has been talking about it for a while
and at last we will be talking about it
and we're gonna have a live demo in a
few minutes so this time we will be like
every other post launch season bringing
you two new operators as well as a new
free map available for everyone to play
as soon as the update goes live this
time we will we will be bringing you to
Brazil our latest location and you will
be visiting the favela map basically in
the favela map it is tightly packed
homes as you can see on the screen that
kind of creates a maze-like structure
you're gonna have to learn about it to
be able to navigate through it from
rooftop to rooftop and house to house we
also switch things around with
destruction
this time we have went with outer shell
destruction this is gonna make attackers
and defenders have to rethink how they
enjoy the map and play the game and
change their habits we also have brought
in two new operators so let's go check
that out right now we have two new baffi
operators for people to enjoy so as you
can see right now we have capital as
well as tavataa that you're gonna be
able to play so let's start with capital
first he's our attacker and what he does
is that he negates positional advantage
of the opposing team in order to do so
he comes equipped with a crossbow he has
two vaults in it the first one being the
asphyxiating bolt which basically does
damage over time in an area so that it's
gonna force his opponent to move away
and the second one is micro smoke
grenades basically like regular grenades
but much more precise and faster to
deploy on the other side we have our
defender
so let's check her out she's more like a
rumor Huntress and what she can do is
punish attackers that get isolated in
order to do so she also has two ways of
doing it
her main ability the one she uses most
often is silent step with it she's gonna
be much more quiet than any other
operator on the field when she moves
this is gonna allow her to reposition
ourselves and surprise enemies the
second ability she she has which is much
more high-risk high-reward is called
interrogation so if she find an operator
in DBM she's going to be able to
interrogate him or her to reveal the
position of their whole team to hurt him
giving a big edge in battle but it's
really tough to pull out so it's quite
exciting what it happens finally another
big thing that we did with this update
is that we launched the alt program this
is really important to us devs because
rainbow is growing right now and we
wanted to make sure to solidify its
foundations so that we can keep building
on the learn long-term on our game and
as you may have heard in the last couple
days we finally launched our battle I
anti cheat client-side in beta and we're
super stoked to do that because we know
the community has been asking for it and
right now we're we feel pretty good
about it I'm pretty happy and right now
as you can see I'm joined by GPL our
game designer on Rainbow six siege be
hey Jane how are you I'm doing great how
are you great very happy to be here yeah
so it's a really special moment for us
today because we learned as looking at
other numbers that that only are we
having the biggest viewership we've ever
have but we never had so many players in
one day playing the game in Rainbow six
and absolutely after its recent it feels
really special for them to learn that
yeah absolutely so really exciting
feeling to see that the game is actually
growing it's I'm so stoked do you want
to talk about the other improvements we
made to the health of the game yeah sure
so lecture said the biggest one is
probably better life or the PC scene I
feel like it's gonna be a game changer
like he's going
secure the producer ranked ladies mostly
but there's a bunch of other things that
we did that I'm really proud of one of
them is like the accuracy of the killcam
is going to get much better we're going
to replicate the field of vision of the
killer so that you get a much better
idea of what exactly happened when he
killed you and there's a bunch of other
improvements and one of the very
important important ones I feel is the
solution that has been brought to the
body clippings for the walls yeah it's a
complex technologies has been developed
to kind of prevent most of the situation
where it's happened it might not be like
entirely perfect but it should eliminate
like most of the occurrences where it's
right it should be much better than
before should be men like any health
related thing that we're working on it's
always gonna be a work in progress
basically because I mean you can always
be better in life right so we strive to
do as best as we can and we're not
giving up and we're gonna keep going and
taking feedback from the community and
absolutely I'm really excited for
everyone to see the new apps the new map
and all the new improvements that we
brought to the game we're gonna be
discussing this in the panel right after
the live demo right now they're still
setting up it's gonna take like one or
two more minutes and meanwhile you can
chat with us so what's your favorite
thing that we added on to season 3b I
gotta say it's probably the map the way
it's played out is super different from
the maps we have so far because of the
outer shell destruction like the whole
approach from the attackers how to be
you have to be very careful like you
really have to be looking for all the
people that defenders might have
prepared but at the same time on the
other side for defenders it's really
really risky if they try to camp too
much inside the objective room cause
basic is again like you can surmise the
whole world you can say can ashes you
can sledge it you can use lots of ways
you can capture the position so it's
really a very warm or heavy map with
lots of lots of way around lots of
things to learn and a lot of discretion
to play with so I'm really excited about
the map and you think any operator is
like best fit into this map like who
would you play on this map I actually
feel like the two new operators
efficient on this map capital is going
to be pretty pretty useful to deny areas
and because because this area is really
like a maze blocking line of sight from
defenders that are trying to roam and
thank you from Z as a rooftop for
instance is going to be super useful and
at the same time kuvira who is really
specialize in lurking is probably going
to be pretty strong too because if she
find a close quarter and like I don't
know a sledge that's flanking or
something that she can punish the other
team really hard all right cool well the
demo is ready so we will see how they
use the new operators in the new map
let's check out who will be playing the
demo we have a quite a cool lineup for
you first off the one you will be
following throughout the demo you're
gonna see a screen here is team it's
seven eighty seventeen are returning
player gasp next to them we have Macy J
also knows as match a next to him you
can see that we have punji stick our
commentator from the pro league and
finally Ashlyn as well as well Renee
they seem to be ready so I think we're
gonna kick it off and we will see how it
goes so let's hope let's see how it goes
let's enjoy it good luck have fun guys
alright we're jumping hello thank you
still miss phone
all right I'm actually gonna run a
hollow here mmm all right I'll do
thermite 10-14 sound good
yep so okay okay yeah yeah so I'm gonna
I'm gonna scalp like the first floor you
guys Scout the tower they're most likely
seriously you okay I wasn't joking being
very serious
you're not supposed to all right let's
go
I wasn't joking how that's what they
told us before we started oh there are
their first floor blood that this
playing pulse okay
okay by the way there is no destruction
of the floor so don't worry about like
c4 on the floor the only thing you might
like be worried about is like travelers
of course but the rest is all
indestructible there's so many angles on
this map okay I have a plan here so just
uh just like can you spawn in the market
can you switch the market everyone nice
nice we're all market okay there's this
big giant wall where we can open it up
and then we can like blended defuser
sort of like almost outside I trust you
yeah yeah a great like open this giant
wall here Mitch a can you like go down
just on this earth do we have breaching
charges by the way yeah okay just open
this wall here oh there's one upstairs
yeah all right fellas yes anything else
okay so who's playing pulse right now
okay so I'm literally just gonna follow
you and you scan the target yeah
yes and then we enter gate and then we
chained them one after the other
yeah Polson kuvira is like nasty
especially on this map because there's a
lot of walls doesn't care about the
outside outside okay so
Bunji Bunji come with me
it's subsonic ammo yeah so are all
suppressors you sure first kill
nice nice nice
you see me await orders there that was
hold my fire can you like right behind
like this way whole lot of nothing along
nothing except above us like by the bomb
okay so there by the bomb guys let's
come up the stairs lost is this safe
they come come to me come to me it's a
big tower looks like we got nothing here
okay don't go up the tower there's a lot
of places where they could like sign
from outside of your range
I don't think I'll be able to in forget
anyone here he's falling back to the
left of that thermite directly on the
other side of me yes okay so you can go
garage you can go garage okay there's a
good thing at the thermite wall on that
he opened there's three there three out
of four the blaze it's outside there's a
lot there's a lot like Northwest
Northwest they're almost all there you
can probably get that kill let's go we
gotta go
I don't have any camera useful how do I
go upstairs to two more enemies I don't
know last one can you try to defeat us
go great save you or win the game I
almost wanted to save you I appreciate
it
instead you elbowed me in there yeah
just elbowed you in the leg over an hour
ago I just wanna be Ashley Sam now you
can't nope yeah I'm no astronaut just
wish it UPS or IQ IQ oh sure that's a
change for mash is actually really good
if they go towers so that would be
really nice
by the way punch you can drop the
defuser if you press X I think yeah
there you go now I almost picked it up
oh cool you okay
yes that's another feature all right I
think it's gonna prove Oh actually no
Bungie approves yeah everybody up there
was sick jumps I I think I'm a fan of
this map yeah it's definitely really
good for pulse caviar oh it's just and
it's all about going outside touch me oh
God
get the skins got to be punji mm-hmm
scans are really hard okay so I don't
know much about this site so let's just
try to like stay as a group yeah I don't
know much about like the flanks and
everything it's a pretty complicated
site actually I spun a little bit away
from the prism
yeah you want you guys want to just push
tower we have a lot we have a line up
yeah we have a lot of like fighting
potential watch the other Tower it looks
good behind you in my channel art calf
countenance could you can go
was that from below is that when I just
Ellis you okay pick it just over to drop
down we nice they didn't look it down on
the mat stuff in someone's role this
year everyone's dying hello yeah
shotguns are really good on this map uh
I wish I had the shotgun okay so there
is a frost and she's probably gonna move
that I don't I don't think she she was
on the right side last scene we're not
sure though are you drawn I could yeah
just send a drone I'll stay on it for
you she was on the right side in here to
the right uh yeah yeah you can probably
like I'm gonna watch that if your uh job
the super 9000 yeah that was a good
showcase of like how good shotguns are
on this map is they're brutal they are
absolutely brutal the thing is that like
it's not only close quarter it's like
there's a lot of destruction and
shotguns are really good at making rid
of holes so it's not only the
destruction but that destruction and
could be used by the long guns yeah yeah
there is definitely like longer hallways
right now the hallway like connects all
the three buildings but it's happening
or tanka that's younger coming to talk
about destruction yeah I need to pick up
some kills now
I think panky wants to kiss me did he
say wants to kiss me okay so reinforce
all the outside wall as per usual it's
pretty much the one thing he wants to
focus on the rest I don't think you have
enough reinforcements this chimney walls
in this map yeah yeah I like it it's
like a choice it's not like there's no
yeah there's no like ultimate strategy
it's like there's drop between the two
sites that drop close this one yeah I
don't think there is it's not even close
I didn't pay attention to the drops too
much well just cuz it's a split I'm
surprised that there is no like yeah
it's the first splits again no variation
so there's no quick rotation back
chunka no I'm gonna try to cover you try
to wallbang people
let's Gramps tears with screamsters blah
bangs boys he's so far away no no he was
on the other side of the building
well now we know that they're very split
up though so don't don't all concentrate
your attention to the tower
I got to buy the tower it sounds good
washing outside stairs I should totally
use that ability I don't use it enough
oh [ __ ]
where is it where's it Tower one Tower
one second I can flank Tower is it the
big Tower the small Tower I have no idea
okay other two AC one in this room two
in this room drop down I'm going up
Tower are they pushing they moved away
from Tower careful careful
I still have one kind I don't really
know what they call that
oh I know exactly what are you are this
room above me now there's like three of
them in this room yeah I know I know
drop Chuck once hit once the other Chuck
tower if you can go up tower you can
actually get the crossbar nervous I'm
coming back to you guys there's no point
in me risking there's two in this room
right here okay is the last two peas in
a he's a knight to a listen
every single reveal I get team kill at
least once like deliberately set aside
for boom kill you and then pause to
excited I got unplugged wait nope we're
not good when I was on the other team
Renee said she was gonna team kill you
if you killed me it looks like it still
happened I thought you were sitting in
front of fire no honestly yeah it was my
fault yeah the important thing is she
ended the round hold on I want to show
the the chat that you can actually play
football
oh yeah yeah you can kick the soccer
ball yeah where is it though I can't I
want to find it yeah in honor of the
all-american grand finals I think we
should call it soccer not football I'm
not gonna that's top floor I can see
them reinforce each other this I don't
know what to call the top but this is
gonna be a wicked Opie drone anyway
like I need to be useful no duty waits
on rooftops you try to go sorry you guys
it's kind of useless okay nice I know
what to do so we just need to all stay
alive and we need to clear the red power
thank you when we played he always tried
to do it okay Mitch hey let's clear this
tower and then push the other one but
it's really open okay
I'm going up there's a lot of places to
flank okay so they have they come in
sight be I think okay well can we can we
get inside the plant I'm checking
I mean B right now Ashley I think B is
clear I'm going to use sounds good I'm
watching stairs on B it smokes planting
sound good okay go repeal repeal
somewhere at all
I don't care where no one nice
I got stairs I can I can smoke the
service to make it awkward for them oh
okay yeah I saw him using stairs
yeah let's go catch some kills in the
board exactly I was nervous
all right yeah that's it that was five
rounds nice for one no it's just a magic